Hey everyone, Ryan here, and welcome back to our head and neck anatomy series of videos.
In this video, we're going to be talking about Facial Space Infections.
And this is an incredibly, incredibly important topic.
I'm actually really excited about this presentation.
It has a lot of clinical relevance.
It appears on all sorts of board exams.
And it also fits in really nicely with head and neck anatomy.
I've wanted to do this topic for a while now, and I feel like it really fits in well with
this content.
So first, let's talk about what the fascia is.
F fascia is thin casing of connective tissue beneath the skin that surrounds and holds
every organ, blood vessel, bone, nerve fiber, and muscle in place.
If you've ever done a cadaver dissection in gross anatomy lab, this is all that stuff
that you're peeling through to get to your nerves and your blood vessels.
It's a lot of the dissecting time is in and through the fascia layers.
There are three distinct layers.
The superficial fascia is a loose connective tissue directly, immediately under the dermis
layer.
The deep fascia is dense connective tissue that's deeper down and surrounds the actual
muscles, bones, nerves, and blood vessels.
And the visceral fascia is that specific layer that suspends organs like the heart and the
lungs within their respective cavities.
So since we're talking about head and neck, let's talk about the superficial cervical
fascia first, fascia within the neck.
It's again located beneath the dermis, between the dermis and the deep cervical fascia.
And it surrounds the platysma muscle.
This is a muscle of facial expression located within your neck, as well as the superficial
vessels and nerves that run there.
The deep cervical fascia is a little bit more complex, and there are four or five specific
layers that we're going to talk about.
The investing layer encloses the sternocleidomastoid muscle and trapezius muscles.
The sternocleidomastoid is out in front anteriorly.
The trapezius muscles are located posteriorly.
The visceral fascia layer surrounds the viscera of the neck.
And so all of those neck organs are being surrounded by this tissue.
The trachea, the esophagus are also located within there.
And so the visceral layer, we can break down further into these two distinct layers.
Pre-tracheal, which is in light blue, that's anterior and located in front of the trachea.
And the bucco-fringiolayer is this light green layer that runs posteriorly to close everything
up there.
The pre-vertebral fascia encloses the vertebral region of the neck, surrounding the vertebral
muscles, the cervical plexus, the brachial plexus, as well as the actual vertebral column.
That's this orange layer here.
And then we have the carotid sheath.
This is this brown circular layer on one on either side.
And it surrounds some really important things.
Encloses the vascular region of the neck, which includes the common carotid artery, the
internal jugular vein, the vagus nerve, or cranial nerve, ten, and the deep cervical
lymph nodes.
All four of those contents are incredibly important to memorize.
So the carotid sheath, one on either side, is enclosing all four of those things.
So that is the deep cervical fascia.
Okay, so now we can talk about fascal spaces, so that deep fascia within the neck, as well
as the head, enclose potential spaces into which infections of dental origin can spread.
Now as a general rule of thumb, infection will always follow the path of least resistance.
So the easiest path for bacteria and their byproducts to travel, by and large, they will
do that.
So this depends on bone density, muscle attachment.
So if you have really dense bone, infection is going to have a much harder time of getting
through there.
If you have a thick muscle attachment, like the masseter that's attaching to that angle
of the ramus, the angle of the mandible, it's going to be very hard for infection to get
past a muscular attachment.
So things like that are important to consider as we move ahead.
Some cardinal signs of infection.
These are pretty classic signs that are, again, another really good thing to kind of lock
in the back of your head, doleur means pain, tumor means swelling, calor means heat, rubour
means redness, and function olesa means loss of function.
So this is referring to things like trismus, which is a lock jaw, dyspnea, difficulty breathing,
phagia, difficulty swallowing, dysponia, difficulty talking, and things like that.
So lots of function loss can be attributed to a spread of infection.
These first four are probably things that might sound familiar from previous lectures
that we've done.
Some vital signs of infection, if we're talking about the integrated board exam, these are
things that might pop up within that patient box, that all important patient box.
So a fever, high temperature, elevated blood pressure, elevated pulse, elevated respiratory
rate, and lymphadenopathy are all vital signs that might be pointing to some infection.
All right, so primary spaces, primary-facial spaces, are those that can be infected via
direct spread from periapical or periodontal infection.
So adanogenic infection can go straight to one of these six primary spaces.
So we're going to go through these one at a time, canine, buckle, submandibular, submental,
and sublingual.
These three are referred to as the peri-mandibular spaces, as well as the vestibular space.
Then of course, we also have secondary spaces.
These are those that are infected via spread from another fascial space.
So another space has to be infected first, either one of these primary spaces, or maybe
even one of these secondary spaces.
And then that space infects another space, which is considered a secondary space.
So we have a couple more here, submasoteric, teregomandibular, superficial, and deep temporal
spaces.
These three collectively are referred to as the masticator space.
We have parapharyngeal, or lateral pharyngeal, retrofaryngeal, the danger space, pre-vertebral
space.
And all four of these are considered deep spaces of the neck.
If we go back to the little drawing that I did here, we're going to be referring back
to that for those four spaces.
And we also have the peri-orbital space.
All right, so let's go through each of these spaces one at a time and unpack what's going
on.
So we're going to start with the vestibular space.
This is the space, the potential space that lies between the cortical bone and the mucoperiostium.
The cortical bone and the mucoperiostium.
This is the most common site for spread of dental infections that break out of alveolar
bone.
Again, the path of least resistance from a specific tooth is determined by the thickness
of bone that's overlying the site of infection and the relationship of bone perforation to
muscle attachments.
So if a tooth, for example, this one on the left is very upright and its root apex is
located closer to the buccal cortical plate, there's a good chance that infection isn't
going to want to go through all of this bone, but rather take the easier way out and travel
through that thinner cortex.
And so this is an example of a vestibular space infection on the facial side.
This one, this tooth that's more proclined, has a less resistance going palatally.
So it travels, again, the path of least resistance, the bone is less thick in that direction.
The muscle attachments, like the mentalis or other muscles that we're going to be talking
about later, can contribute to limiting that spread of infection and creating boundaries
for that infection that make it harder to cross over.
The canine or infraorbital space lies between the levator, anguli, orus muscle and the levator
lebi superioris muscles, these two levator, I should say, levator muscles are muscles
of facial expression as well.
So it lies between those muscles superficial to the canine fossa of the maxilla.
So we're looking right at this region right here below the eye in that canine space.
Infection presents with swelling of the vestibule, the upper lip, and even the lower eyelid
could get involved here if that swelling really progresses.
The usual dental source, the odontogenic origin for a canine space infection, is a maxillary
canine or a maxillary tizer, can also contribute to infection of this space.
Again, path of least resistance, those root apices are pretty close to this potential
facial space.
The periorbital space lies between the orbicularis orus muscle and the orbital septum, and so
it's right here in that orbit.
And the infection presents with redness and swelling of the eyelid and it may actually
obstruct vision, which is when it gets very, very serious.
The path of least resistance is going to be from that canine space.
So the canine space is a primary space, can be infected straight from one of these teeth.
Periorbital is a secondary space that can get infected via the canine space.
The buckle space lies between the buxinator muscle, which is right here, and the skin.
And this is also the location of the buckle fat pad.
Infection presents with marked cheek swelling, so one of their cheeks is just going to be
way enlarged, and especially if it's been around a while and this infection has had time
to cook.
And the usual dental source for a buckle space infection is a premolar or a molar.
The sublingual space is located down here and it's located just under the tongue above
the myelohyoid muscle.
It's also the location of that sublingual gland.
And swelling for this one would be evident in the floor of the mouth.
The usual dental source for a sublingual space infection is a mandibular incisor, canine,
premolar, or first molar.
What's really important here is that all of these teeth have roots above the attachment
of the myelohyoid muscle to the myelohyoid line.
So usually this is the case that incisor canine premolar, sometimes that first molar
might not be, have its roots above the attachment of the myelohyoid muscle.
But the most important thing here is that again, like we talked about before, muscles
and muscle attachments, like this one here, create a boundary that makes infection very,
very hard to cross through.
So if, let's say, this canine root extends here and the apex is where the infection
is, it can pierce through the cortical plate on the lingual surface and spread into that
sublingual space.
But if this, let's say, second molar had a root apex that went down below the myelohyoid
muscle.
Well, now we're talking about a different space altogether that happens below the myelohyoid
So because of the location of those roots and the myelohyoid muscle attachment, that
is why swelling is evident in the floor of the mouth and also why the dental infection
would most likely spread to the point above this myelohyoid muscle in the sublingual space.
Now if we go to the submandibular space, swelling would be evident at the submandibular triangle.
And the usual dental source for this one is the mandibular second or third molar whose
roots are below the attachment of the myelohyoid muscle to that line.
So this is the example that I was just proposing.
If you have long roots of a second molar or a third molar, the infection would pierce
through the lingual cortical plate into the submandibular space located below the myelohyoid
muscle.
Lastly we have the submental space.
This would be evident at the chin below the chin between the anterior bellies of the digastric.
That's where the submental triangle is.
The usual dental source for this one is a mandibular incisor.
This one would be a longer root mandibular incisor.
So Ludwig's angina is an important clinical manifestation to talk about because it can
certainly appear on the board exam as an aggressive form of cellulitis.
That's a diffuse spread of infection through phasal planes of soft tissue.
The Ludwig's angina involves swelling in all three of the perimandibular spaces.
The ones we just talked about, sublingual, submandibular, and submental.
This swelling in all three of those perimandibular spaces elevates the floor of the mouse, which
displaces the tongue upwards and backwards, which then blocks the oropharynx, which then
compromises the airway.
So it's this domino series of events that contributes ultimately to airway compromise,
which is, of course, very, very serious.
Now it's going to present clinically as an underrated, a hard, massive bilateral swelling
of the chin and the neck.
It can also spread to the mediastinum, which is a cavity that houses some very important
things like the heart and it can get there via phascial spaces of the neck, which we're
going to talk about in a little bit.
And of course that can be very, very serious for other reasons.
So the superficial and deep temporal spaces result, if you have an infection of those
spaces, it's going to result as this lateral hourglass facial swelling.
So this is what they're calling an hourglass shape, where you have two parts that stick
out.
So you're getting this expansion at the temple and also the cheek, and around the zygomatic
arch area that's staying constricted.
The usual dental source for an infection of this space is a maxillary second or third
molar.
The sub-masoteric, also called the masseteric space, lies between the masseter and the
ramus.
And infection with this in this space frequently involves trismus, this lock jaw you're having
not able to open all the way or at all.
And the usual dental source is an impacted third molar.
The last mass-decator space we have to talk about is the Terego mandibular space, and
this one lies between the medial pterygoid and mandibular ramus.
It contains the sphenomandibular ligament, inferior alveolar nerve and vessels, lingular
nerve and the cordotimpany.
It's also the space that's accessed from the oral cavity through the buccinator muscle
for inferior alveolar nerve blocks.
The usual dental source is a mandibular third molar that's infected.
This could be from a cavity, it could be from pericornitis, or a contaminated needle involved
in an IAN block that contaminates this space.
This is a high-risk infection due to the close proximity to the lateral pharyngeal space.
This is one of those deep neck spaces that gets more and more dangerous as we go back.
So the mass-decator spaces are the last three we talked about, the temporal spaces, the masseteric
spaces and the Terego mandibular space.
They're called mass-decator space collectively because they all involve the muscles of mass
-decation, and here is a drawing of those muscles and the spaces that they create boundaries
for.
And here, just like in my previous videos in this series, I have simplified it into a diamond
with all of the information that you need to know to be able to reproduce this in your
head for any kind of test question you might get concerning the mass-decator space.
So let me explain how I've laid this out.
I basically have simplified the shapes so that you can make it a lot easier to remember,
and I guess I'll start with the four muscles of mass-decation.
We have the temporalis muscle, which runs up and down like this.
We have the lateral pterygoid muscle, which runs side to side, and I'm just highlighting
these muscles here.
And those muscles attach to the mandible, which is running up like this, and I want
to clarify, we're looking at the left side of the face looking from behind a person.
So if we cut this skull in half, we're basically looking at a cross-section from the back of
the head at the left side of their skull.
So the temporalis is inserting into the cordonoid process.
The lateral pterygoid is inserting into the condyle up at the top of the mandible.
And we're going to talk about this in a future video.
And we also have to round out the center of this diamond, the zygomatic arch running
laterally like this.
We have the masseter muscle that goes from zygomatic arch to the bottom of the mandible
on the lateral side.
It attaches to the lateral surface of the mandibular angle.
The medial pterygoid runs and attaches to the medial angle of the mandible.
So it creates that nice little diamond shape like this.
And then for the last few bounds, we just have the skin of the face on the outside and the
skull on the inside.
Once we have all of that completed, now we have a really nice diamond that we just can
fill in those four spaces.
I'm going to change this color to orange to match my other, the bones that I've colored
in an orange.
So now all we have to do is fill in these four spaces.
We have the superficial temporal space over here that's superficial to the temporalis
muscle.
And then we have the deep temporal space, which is deep to the temporalis muscle.
We also have this little subsection of the deep temporal space located below the temporal
bone, and that's called the infrared temporal space.
That's again, that's about where we are talking about the infrared temporal fossa.
That's where we were in the last video.
And then we have the sub-massoteric space that's below underneath the masseter muscle.
And then we have the pterygoid mandibular space, which get ready for this one, is located
between the medial pterygoid muscle and the mandible.
And so all of those names actually make perfect sense.
And maybe they didn't before, but hopefully now you're able to see that, yeah, those names
really do make sense and they correspond to their location within the mouth.
So that is a nice simple way of looking at the massicular space.
All right, so now we're going to go to the deep spaces of the neck.
The paraffaryngeal or lateral pharyngeal space, these are synonymous terms, lies between the
masticator space anteriorly and the retrofaryngeal space posteriorly.
So it's located between the masticator and between the retrofaryngeal that we'll talk
about next.
So we're right in this region.
The infection of this space usually presents with swelling of a tontal and the lateral
pharyngeal wall on the affected side.
And usually you have very, very painful swallowing with this infection of this space.
The usual dental source is a mandibular third molar.
It's a very high risk space since it's very close to the retrofaryngeal space.
Not only that, it's continuous with it, so there's no border technically between the
lateral and the retrofaryngeal spaces.
So let's move to that one next.
Now we're talking about this space back here at the back of the throat and it lies between
the bucco-faryngeal fascia and the aller fascia.
So if I go back to our drawing here, now we're talking about for the retrofaryngeal space,
we're talking about, let me use this red color.
We're talking about this space right in here.
So it's located between the bucco-faryngeal fascia and this one which is called the aller
fascia.
Okay, so we are in this space right now, retrofaryngeal.
And the retrofaryngeal space spans vertically from the base of the skull all the way down
to the mediastinum.
So it's very high risk because it is essentially a highway of infection spread from the head
down to the mediastinum which again houses a bunch of vital organs.
And then we have the danger space and this one lies between the aller fascia and the
pre-vertebral fascia.
So let's go back to our deep cervical fascia.
The danger space is located here.
It's between the aller fascia here and the pre-vertebral fascia which is here.
The danger space and retrofaryngeal spaces are often confused with each other.
I've seen a bunch of sources online that confuse these all the time and I want to make sure
make this clear to you guys that these are two separate spaces.
The danger space spans from the base of the skull to the posterior mediastinum and diaphragm.
So it actually goes even further down into the body and this is an extremely high risk
due to just a highway of infection spread to a really important part of the body.
So that's an extremely, extremely serious infection if you have infection of that space.
And the last one I wanted to talk about is the parotid space.
I haven't really seen this one come up on board exams too often.
Infection here presents with medial bulge of the lateral pharyngeal wall, pain and that
lock jaw.
It's usually not involved in the spread of dental infections.
So usually not an odontogenic origin here but it's rather caused by a paratitis, cellulolithiasis
or showgrine syndrome.
So it's usually non-odontogenic in origin.
And treatment for a facile space infection could range based on its severity as well as
its source.
So if it's an odontogenic origin we can think about extraction or pulpectomy.
If there is a large swelling we can think about incision and drainage to decrease the
bacterial load, to relieve the pressure and the pain and to increase blood flow to the
site to flush it out.
We can also think about antibiotic coverage.
This would be if we have diffuse swelling, if the facile spaces are involved, if there
is systemic manifestations like fever, tachycardia, lymphadenopathy, then antibiotic coverage
can certainly be considered.
Alright so that's it for this video guys.
I hope you enjoyed it.
I spent a lot of time putting this one together and trying to make it clinically relevant.
So hopefully you found that enjoyable and thank you so much for watching.
Please like this video if you did enjoy it and subscribe to this channel for more on
dentistry.
If you're interested in supporting this channel and what I do, please check out my
Patreon page.
Thank you to all of my patrons for all of their support.
You can unlock extras like access to my video slides to take notes on and practice questions
for the board exams.
So go check that out, the link is in the description.
Thanks again for watching everyone and I'll see you in the next video.